Today
today we're,
we're still focused on
individual consciousness,
uh, why you might ask, well,
as the site or model for symbolic
patterning of one sort or another,
uh,
we can speak of the psycho
genesis of the text or film,
uh, perhaps in the case,
certainly have Jijak, uh,
to some extent also have Dilas. Uh, and,
and therefore we can still
understand today's readings online,
uh,
Thursday's readings as belonging to the
psychological emphasis in our syllabus.
This is actually our farewell to
the psychological emphasis. And,
uh, it is, uh,
so arranged because there are intimations
in today's authors that there are
political stakes.
That is to say in one way or another,
we're to understand their argument about
the way in which the psyche functions
as a, as having political
implications. Uh, [inaudible],
uh, is fascinating. It seems to me and
his brilliant reading of the crying game,
uh, at the very end of your essay
in the moment when he says, look,
this isn't just a kind of
abdication from responsibility for,
um, uh, the IRS republican
revolution. Uh, the,
the soldier has not merely walked away
from his role in revolutionary activity.
He has discovered in his private
life that is to say in the, in,
in, in the erotic dimension
of his consciousness,
the need for revolution from within,
he has disrupted his per necessarily
disrupted his own thinking,
uh,
in ways equally radical too and closely
parallel to the disruption of thinking
that's required to understand,
uh,
one's relationship with the emerging,
stat republican status of Ireland.
And so says [inaudible] Jack,
there are political implications
for the upheaval in consciousness.
That is, uh, it,
it ultimately tragic and counter
with the big other and tails.
Uh, I should say in passing
also about Jijak that, um,
as your editor I think goes into this a
little bit in the italicized preface up,
that there are temptations,
political temptations entailed
in this fascination with,
uh,
and,
or even perhaps transcendent object
of desire for the individual,
but also for the social psyche.
In religious terms,
there is a perhaps surprising
or counterintuitive
friendliness toward religion
in Jack's work on the grounds that
faith or the struggle for faith,
uh,
after all does constitute and effort
to enter into some kind of meaningful
relationship with that which one
desires yet at the same time can't have.
And by the same token,
and this is where, uh,
this is where in certain moments he
confesses to a kind of instability in his
political thinking,
even though he is by and large on the left
and partly needs to be understood, uh,
as a disciple of Mark's.
Nevertheless,
he recognizes that in politics there's
a kind of excitement but also perhaps
potential danger in fascination
with a big idea. Uh,
it could be of course, some form
of progressive colleague activity.
It could,
on the other hand be the kind of big
idea that countenance is the rise of
fascism. Uh, Jijak
acknowledges this, that the,
that public identification with a kind of,
uh,
of almost or completely
inaccessible otherness,
either as a political idea or as
a charismatic political leader.
Um, can after all, uh, open up a, uh,
a vertigo of dangerous possibilities.
I use the word vertical advisedly
because I'm going to be coming back to
Hitchcock to, I'm going to be
coming back to Hitchcock's vertigo,
vertigo in just a minute.
Um, but in the meantime,
they're also obviously political stakes
in Dulles to those of course presents to
us in the for in this first chapter
of his book a thousand plateau.
Uh, he presents to us a
kind of thought experiment,
both as something
recommended to the reader,
see if you can think in this new,
so radically,
radically innovative way,
but also providing a model for
thinking of this kind in the style and
organization and composition
of the chapter itself.
So as a thought experiment,
uh, once again, uh,
Delores has to do in thought with what
you might call a revolution from within.
But the implications once again in
politics as indeed also for Jijak,
uh,
are somewhat ambiguous.
That is to say the
rhizomatic mode of thinking.
And we'll come back to the rhizomatic,
uh,
mode of thinking as we go along,
um,
with which radically de Centering,
uh,
and which lends itself to
identification with, as it were,
the mass movement of Kali
activity can plainly be,
uh, uh, uh, progressively democratic.
That is to say democratic beyond even
what are social and cultural cultural
hierarchies accommodate.
But at the same time,
or I should say it can once again
be fascistic because, because,
uh, the, because the organization
of fascistic culture,
while nevertheless a kind of top down
arrangement where the fruit her involves
is nevertheless as,
uh,
the mass is mobilized nevertheless
in this mobilization, uh,
rhizomatic
delos is careful to point out that
in the, that, that there, that,
that rhizomes and rhizomatic thinking is
as he says repeatedly for the best and
worst,
rats are rhizomes.
Crab grass is a rhizome.
In other words,
everything which organizes
itself in this fashion, uh,
is rhizomatic. Much of it as
a I'll be coming back to, uh,
try to explain with a little more care
is for the good into those as view.
By the way, I say de Luz,
and the same way I said,
Wimsatt got tare is an important
colleague. And ally, uh,
they wrote many books together,
including one that I'll mention later.
They also wrote things separately,
but Dullas simply because his
oeuvre is more ample. And,
and people feel somehow or another that
he's more central to this work. Um, is a,
is a Synecdoche d for
Dilas and [inaudible].
And so I'll be saying to those, but
I don't mean to slight. Got Dowry.
Uh, in any case, uh, so, so, uh, we'll be,
we'll be examining, uh, the,
the delivery and rhizome a little bit
more closely, but in the meantime, um,
as to its political implications and
we are moving closer to the political,
uh, as we, as we began to think
about figures of this kind, uh,
is really on the admission of
both of them, somewhat ambiguous.
In other words, they're introducing new
possibilities of thought and as, and,
and they're very different
from each other as we'll see.
They're introducing new
possibilities of thought, uh,
but there Canada enough to admit that
they don't quite know where these
possibilities are going.
That you know, what, what,
what the implications or consequences of
successfully entering the thought world
of either one of them might
be. All right. So, um, yes, uh,
they,
they certainly have very different ideas
that I wouldn't blame you for saying
why on earth are we reading
these two texts together? Uh,
the overlap isn't altogether clear. I'm
going to suggest what it is in a minute.
But in the,
uh,
they are certainly on about
very different things.
Diller's uh, concerned
with the, with as I say,
introducing a kind of thought experiment
which has to do with the de-centering
of thought. Getting away from the
tree or rars model of thought.
We'll have more to say about that.
And uh, [inaudible] on the other hand,
following lock cause distinction between,
uh,
the object, uh, ready to
hand that you can have a,
if you want and the object of desire,
which such is the chain of signification
is perpetually something that exceeds
a, are out distances. Our grasp,
uh, in developing this idea,
uh,
and thinking about what the object desire
in all of its manifold forms might be,
develops this curious idea, which is
at the center of his thinking, uh,
of the blot that,
that the,
the element in narrative form the element
and the way in which our storytelling
capacities are organized,
which really can't be narrative,
which were narrated,
which really can't lend itself to meaning.
Meaning of course,
concrete specific meaning being
that which can be tied down, uh,
to, uh, to an accessible
object. And so, uh, so the,
the central idea that Jijak is attempting
to develop in his essay is this has to
do with this notion of the relationship
between the big other and the blood as
we'll see. So these, these, these strike
one is being extremely different ideas.
And as I say, I wouldn't
blame you for wondering, uh,
just what overlap there can
be. Well, at the same time,
I would think that as you
read these two, uh, rather,
the somewhat a bouncy and frantic pros
of both of these have both of these
texts.
You did say that they had a kind of
mood or stance or orientation toward the
critical and theoretical
project in common.
They seem in other words,
uh,
to be of the same moment and then
even though their ideas seemed to,
to be so very different,
that is the basic idea is they're
trying to get across seem to be so very
different.
You could perhaps imagine these two
texts as being written if it was just a
question of considering their
style by the same person. Uh,
I actually, I think that's not quite true,
but at the same time, the, the, the, the,
the kind of high energy too caffeinated,
a feeling that you get from
the pros of both, uh, is,
is, is something that might
give you pause, uh, and ask
and make you wonder, well,
just what,
what moment does this belong to?
The answer is important and
in a way obvious. I'm sure.
I'm sure all of you are ready to
tell me what moment it belongs to.
It belongs to post modernism.
This, these, these are,
these are two exemplars of what
is by far the most slippery.
Um, if one likes it, one
wants to say versatile,
if one doesn't like it,
one wants to say murky concept,
uh, to which we've been exposed in
the last 20 or 30 years. And, and,
and I think that,
um,
I think that in a way we can bring them
both into focus as a pair a little bit.
If we pause somewhat simply
over the concept postmodernism,
I mean,
maybe that's one of the things you wanted
to learn and taking a course like this.
So, so, uh, I'm just providing
a service, um, you know, so,
so, so postmodernism, what
is, what is postmodernism?
I think we know what it is in
artistic expression. Uh, we've,
uh, we've encountered enough
examples of it. Uh, we are,
we have perhaps even taken courses in
which in the context of artistic form and
expression, it has come up
postmodernism in artistic expression,
particularly in the visual arts. But
I think this is, this is true of us.
Have of certain movements in both
narrative and poetry as well.
Postmodernism is an eclectic
orientation to the past.
In a certain sense,
it's a return to the past.
It's an opening up of textual possibility
to traditions and historical moments
of expression,
which modernism had tended to suppose
obsolete and to have set aside.
So that in artistic expression,
as I say,
postmodernism is an eclectic return to
possibilities thrown up by the history of
art and literature. So that,
I mean in architecture, um,
many examples are quite extraordinary
and many unfortunately are also hideous.
You know,
that there was a certain point 15 or
20 years ago when every strip mall,
every shopping mall was redecorated
or what's the word I want,
renovated every shopping mall was
random. And how did they renovate it? Uh,
they'd been flat, you know, they'd
been sort of means Vander roa,
sort of sixties modern before then it
just sat there flat and so the renovators
came along and put little gables on,
on the,
on the shopping mall so that each,
each little shopped in the mall now has
a gable and this is postmodern and the
most awful things were
done with suburban houses.
Also it also in the name of
a, of, of a kind of blind,
completely, completely tasteless
return to the neoclassical and,
and certain other aspects of tradition.
So the postmodern in what you might call
suburban culture has been pretty awful.
Uh,
but at the same time it has entailed
a great deal of interesting work in
painting. All of a sudden, you know,
the New York scene isn't just one
school and that's the sign of it.
It's not just a certain
kind of abstraction.
It's not just a wholesale,
a return agreed on by everyone to realism.
It's a mixture of everything.
Uh, so that, so that every,
it's not just the artists are always
just completely obsessed with their place
in art history.
It's not just a groups of artists together
wanting to identify a certain place
for themselves in art history.
It's every artist and a kind of a
narcotic independence from the thinking of
other artists, uh, coming to terms
with our history in his or her own way.
Uh,
so that the scene,
the art scenes of New York and Berlin and
Los Angeles and saw on the scene isn't
something that you can identify as
having a certain character anymore.
It's postmodern precisely
in that it's gone global.
It has a million influences and sources
and there's very little agreement among
artists about how to amalgamate and put
these sources together so that in terms
of artistic expression,
the way in which the postmodern
moment after modernism,
in other words, the postmodern
moment presents itself and I,
and I put it deliberately
as a medical symptom,
the way that the way the
postmodern moment presents, uh, in,
in artistic expression.
Now, philosophically,
philosophically, postmodernism
can be understood about as doubt,
not just about the grounds of
knowledge or you know, the, the,
the widespread sorts of dot,
which,
which we've been talking about more
or less continuously in this course.
It can be understood as
doubt in particular about
the relationship between or
among parts and wholes.
In other words,
can I be sure that my leg is part of
my body when plainly it is at the same
time, all whole with
respect to my foot. How,
how is it that I know,
uh, in any stable way?
What a part or a whole list to take
a more interesting example, uh, this,
this is in Vichtenstein
Phillip Philosophical
Investigations. There is the flag,
the French flag, which is
called the tri color. All right,
now the tri color is made up of
three strips of color, white, blue,
and red. I'm sorry if I've
gotten the order wrong. In fact,
I'm almost positive that I have, uh, um,
but there are those three strips of color,
uh, existing in relation
to each other. And plainly,
those three strips of color are
parts of the flag and they, and,
and they have a certain symbolic value.
That is to say each color
represents something, uh,
and editors and enters into the symbolic
understanding of what the flag is.
But at the same time, red, white,
and blue. Oh, sorry. Yes. Red,
white and blue aren't confined
to this piece of cloth.
The little strips of white,
red and blue are obviously parts,
uh, of whiteness. They can't be,
they can't be understood as parts
simply in and of themselves or parts
specifically of one thing.
There are parts of other things as well,
but what's more,
you know,
if you look at the tri color without
knowing what you're looking at, uh,
how can you say that it's the part
of a whole, you say, well, you know,
they're just, they're
just parts, uh, they are,
or their holes unto themselves,
which somebody happens to have laid
a side by side. By the same token,
if you look at the part of the tri color,
which was white and you say white,
well,
obviously with respect to the
vast universalizing concept,
white,
a little flag is simply a kind of met
a Nimic relationship with that sense of
white,
but to,
but to concretize this idea of the
problematic relationship between part and
whole and a different way,
how can we be,
why are we so confident
about what we see as, as,
as most of you know,
I'm sure philosophical thinking tends
to be tyrannized by metaphors of vision.
We assume that we understand reality
because I'm not altogether as consciously,
metaphorically speaking about
this as perhaps we might be. Um,
we say that we can see it,
but how do you see it?
You see it because of the Lenzing
or focusing capacities of the eye,
which exercise a certain tyranny
over the nature of what you see.
If you look too closely at something,
all you can see is dots.
If you close your, if you look at
something and close your eyes, uh,
that too becomes a kind of vast
retinal mark Tobey painting.
And, and, and, you know, it has a
relation to what, to what to what you see,
but is at the same time
something very different.
So if you get too far away from objects,
they dissolve what you thought was an
object dissolves into a much vaster,
greater space,
which has seems to have
another objective nature.
The space that you, if you're in
a jet and you're looking down a,
what you're seeing certainly looks
like it has form and structure,
but the form and structure is not at all
what you're seeing if you're standing
on the ground. Uh, looking at
exactly the same, shall we say,
a square footage a insofar as you can,
you're simply seeing different things.
And if you recognize what might be
called the tyranny of focus in the way in
which we orient ourselves to the world,
you can see that this perpetual dissolve
and refocus constituting objects
perpetually in new ways. And this happens
to, you know, and the history of science.
Uh,
the relationship between
subatomic particles sometimes
turns itself inside out.
And the particle that you thought was the
fundamental unit, uh, turns out in fact,
to have, uh, to, to, to, to have, uh,
within it a fundamental unit
of which it is apart and there.
And I mean, all of this was, uh, I'm just,
I'm just referring to what happened
during the golden age of the linear
accelerator, when, when, uh,
when all sorts of remarkable sort
of inversions of what's taken to be
fundamental, um, seemed, uh, to be, uh,
made available by the experimental data.
So that in all of these ways,
uh, ranging from scientific to, uh,
to sim to the most subjectively visual
ways of understanding the world,
there are possibilities of doubt
that can be raised about part whole
relationship. What is a whole,
how do we define a unity?
Should we be preoccupied with the
nature of reality as a set of unity's
obviously delivers is
extremely upset about this,
but he doesn't want anything to do with
unity. Uh, he doesn't, he, he, he, he,
his whole,
the whole function of his thought
experiment is the decentering of things.
So that's that one can no longer talk
about units or holes or isolated entities.
It's the being together and
merging together and flying apart,
uh,
and reuniting and nieces,
movement of entities if they can even
be called entities that diverse is
concerned with.
Now,
another aspect of the postmodern
is what the postmodern philosopher,
uh,
John Francois [inaudible] in particular
has called the inhuman or the process of
the dehumanization of the human.
Now this isn't this,
this is a weird term to choose because
it's not an all addy humanistic.
It's really a new way of thinking
about the human dilemmas.
You'll notice talks not just
here in, in, in this episode,
by repeatedly throughout his work,
uh,
which is why he has a little to say
about it here. That's explanatory.
He talks about Oregon's without bodies
that might've brought you up short.
Uh,
but what it suggests is that we are,
as delivers would put it
machinic rather than organic. Uh,
if the problem with centered flaw is
that it thinks of everything as Arba real
as a tree.
That problem has to do with the fact
that a tree is understood in its symbolic
extensions to have Oregon's,
the roots are muscles and circulation.
The blossoms are genital in nature.
The crown or canopy of leaves is the
mind of the tree reaching up to the sky,
the mentality of the tree.
And by the same token,
if we think of our own
bodies as Arba Real,
we think of certain parts of
those bodies as cognitive,
other parts of those bodies, as
having agency, as doing things.
And if that's the case, then
we think of a centered, uh,
uh,
and,
and ultimately genital or
genetic understanding of the
body as being productive.
Dullas wants to understand the body
as being interactive, as being,
uh, polymorphous perverse. So
among other things, he wants to,
he wants to understand it
as being everywhere and
nowhere and unsaturated body
among other bodies.
And in order for this to happen,
it's interface with other things has
to be without agency and also without,
uh, with, with, with,
without co cognitive, uh,
intention, uh, on the
model of I think therefore,
I am the world comes into
being because I think, uh,
without any of this in
play, in other words, we,
the d the dehumanization of the postmodern
has to do not at all with denying the
importance of the human,
but with this radical way of rethinking
the human among other bodies and things.
Plainly,
this emphasis involves a kind
of dissolving into otherness,
a continuity between subject and object,
uh,
in which the difference ultimately
between what is inside me,
what is authentic or in
integral to my being me,
uh,
and what's outside me become completely
permeable and interchangeable.
The late 19th century,
a author and philosopher, aesthetic
philosopher, Walter pater,
in the conclusion to a famous book
of his called the Renaissance,
had a wonderful way of putting this.
He said,
we're too used to thinking that we're in
here and everything else is out there.
And that somehow or
another, our perspective on
everything out is a kind of,
of of,
uh,
saving isolation are enabling
our power of objectivity,
but then paid her says,
how can this be?
Because we're made up of the
same things that's out there.
We to our molecular and other words,
what does in us rusts
iron and ripens corn.
There is a continuousness between the
inside feeling we have about ourselves and
the x Doria,
the exteriority with we're with which
we are constantly coming in contact.
Uh,
so this is a,
I mean the Dolos and Guattari
of course have their own, um,
excited junk be away of
putting these things,
but it's not really a new idea that we
exaggerate the isolation of consciousness
from its surroundings.
There is a,
there is a permeability of inside and
outside that this kind of rise ohmic or d
centered thinking, uh,
is Matt to focus on?
No,
you could say that Wa
Dullas is interested in it.
If you go back to our coordinates
that we kept, you know, when we're,
when we're talking about the formulas,
so sewer through
structuralism deconstruction.
If you go back to those coordinates, you
can say that what does is interested in,
ah,
like so many others we've read is a
rendering virtual or possibly even
eliminating of the vertical axis.
In other words of that center
or head or crown of the tree,
which constitutes everything that
unfolds on the horizontal access,
be it language, be it the unconscious,
structured like a language, be it,
whatever it might be. You
could say that, uh, the, that,
that the project of villas to as the
undoing or rendering virtual virtual of
this vertical access. Well,
in a way I think that's true,
but then what is the horizontal axis that,
that,
that is where the relation of dilemmas to,
let's say deconstruction becomes a
little problematic and where are we can
actually see a difference.
I got to compare him in,
there's one respect with luck call,
but I want to hasten to point
out as I will in a minute. Uh,
a divergence from Lacan as well.
You remember that?
And Lock Cause Agency of the letter
essay, he says, you know, he,
he doesn't just talk about the access
of combination as a series of concentric
circles, each one of which is made up
of little concentric circles. He's, uh,
he doesn't just talk about that.
He also talks about the way
in which the combinatory, uh,
powers of the imaginary in language or
desire and language take place is like a
musical staff,
uh,
the w and so that the organization of
signs in their Kata guity with each other
can be either melodic or harmonic.
Uh, but in any case, the,
you can't just think of the axis of
combination as a complete linearity.
It has, it has a dimensionality
of different kinds,
well for,
for,
and that's why Deleuze and
Guattari introduced the
concept of Plateau toward the
end of your excerpt.
The book in which your excerpt appears
is called a thousand plateaus. Uh,
and ultimately the concept of Plateau
is even more important to them than the
concept of rhizome. The what, when
they introduced the concept of Plateau,
they're doing exactly the same thing.
They're saying we jump from
sign cluster to sign cluster.
And not all zine clusters
are linear and uniform.
This is where there is perhaps a
difference from deconstruction.
Deleuze and Guattari are interested in
multiplicity of coding as they put it.
They're interested in the,
in the way in which, um,
when I think I'm not just thinking in
language, I'm not just thinking, uh,
pictorially. I'm not just
thinking musically, uh,
but I am leaping around
among codes so that, uh,
the actual thought process
is eclectic in this way. Um,
now you could say that this is something
actually anticipated also by Lacan.
You remember also in the agency essay
that Lacan reminds us a true inheritor of
Freud,
which he takes himself to be.
Lecar reminds us that at the beginning
of the interpretation of dreams,
Freud said that the decoding,
the dreamwork as like figuring
out the puzzle of a reverse,
a reverse being, one of those, uh, uh,
trick sentences which are made up not
exclusively of words but have the odd
syllable.
But then of pictures I heart New York,
I heart New York is a rebus,
uh,
and that and that the dream work functions
constantly in Freud's view as a river.
So you could say that luck on already
introduces a four Dullas the possibility
of thinking of a multiple coding that
needs to be decoding a on a variety of
decoded on a variety of plateaus
if it's going to make any sense.
Um,
now
d delays his relationship with all the
figures we've been reading is rather
problematic. Really. Um,
the book preceding a thousand
plateaus was called Auntie Oedipus.
And it is a continuous
systematic attack on, for,
on the eye. He always calls
Freud the general, uh, and the I,
the idea that, um, that, that,
that Freud feels that the whole of our
psychic lives is completely saturated
and,
and dominated by the Oedipus
complex and does, you know,
with his idea of decent thinking
of rise of the rhizome ah,
so that's out to show in a
variety of ways how limiting, uh,
and how unfortunate for the legacy
of psychoanalysis, this kind of,
of, of, of, of focus
on a particular issue.
It turns out to be this is,
this is delivers his critique of Freud,
not mine. And it's, and, and
you would think that does,
then we'd be a lot closer to Lacan just
for the reasons that I've just described.
But you know what call too,
there's a,
at the very bottom of page, uh,
what page is it at the very bottom,
bottom of, um, uh, in
your text, uh, oh three,
four left on the right hand column,
very bottom of the page.
He says,
it is no accident that psycho psycho
analysis linked it's destiny with
linguistics. Now it's, it's impossible
to say, I think quite by design,
it's impossible to say whether Diller's
is referring to Freud or Lacan and
saying that because it's locked
car who claims that Freud said it.
In other words,
that the interpretation of dreams is
the text in which we discover that the
unconscious is structured like a
language. Um, but at the same time, uh,
uh,
posterity has taken a lot cause
focus on linguistics to be a massive,
perhaps inappropriate
revision of Freud, uh, and uh,
to be a very different matter. So, uh,
it's interesting that delivers quite
ambiguously scenes to suppose for us that
Freud and Lacan are part
and parcel of each other.
And the reason he can do that is that
he is interested in a form of thinking
about language, which no
linguistics has successfully, uh,
accommodated as far as he's concerned.
In other words,
he keeps talking about
Chomsky. Uh, you know, uh,
John's can seems to be in a way
the villain of your essay. Uh, but,
but I think in a way that's just the
way of evading talking about so serve
because you wouldn't want to get in
trouble with all those structuralists uh,
because so sort of to,
uh,
the problem was so sir too is that
there is a certain tyranny or Arbor ask
tendency and so Syria and thinking,
uh,
to be focused on the binary,
that is the relationship between the
signified and signifier as fixed,
as inflexible as lacking in what
dairied I would call free play, uh,
and therefore to,
or kind of a kind of of tyranny.
So very quickly on the rhizome,
how do we know a rhizome when we see it?
I think probably in the long run,
whatever frustrations,
uh, uh, the don't delivers
his essay puts in your path.
I think probably in the long run you're,
you're pretty clear on what
a rhizome is, but if, but,
but if there's any lingering doubt,
just think about the flu. Um,
there, there is, uh,
what Dolores calls rhizomatic flu.
That's something we get from other people.
The circulation of disease as we all
come down with it around midterm period.
The circulation of disease is rhizomatic.
It's a perfect example of Ah,
to use another tool to use another
instance from, from dilemmas,
the relationship between the wasp
and the orchid, the wasp like the,
like the, the virus, um,
sort of flits about
from blossom to blossom,
descends and then constitutes the flu.
And by contrast there is
hereditary disease that is
that which is lurking in us,
uh, because we're programmed for
it. We're hardwired for, for it. Uh,
it is, it is genetically
in our nature and this, uh,
the Dilas associates with Arbarella,
with the arb arrest, it is,
uh, it comes from an origin. It is,
it is something that is a cause within
us or a cause standing behind us as
opposed to something coming
out of left field, uh,
in an arbitrary and unpredictable
fashion and descending on us brats.
Also not unlike 10 yon offs,
distinction between
modification and evolution.
The arborist evolves.
The rhizomatic is modification
that you know, the, the, the,
the give and take of
tensions among entities.
The rats tumbling over each other,
the maze of the borough,
they spreading of crab grass.
All of this,
all of this has a kind of randomness,
unpredictability of the power of linkage
at all conceivable points without any,
without any predictability.
Uh, all of this, uh,
is entailed in the rhizomatic
now as to what's being attacked.
And again, the value system surrounding
these things are not absolute.
Dulles is not going so far
as to say arborist, bad.
Rhizomatic good. He's coming pretty close
to it, but he acknowledges the perils,
as I say, of the rhizomatic.
But in the meantime,
just one point in passing because I'm
running out of time to talk about Jijak.
Just one point in passing
about the arborist.
They're actually in the first pages
of your essay. Two forms of it.
One is what he calls the
route book and other,
the traditional classical
book which presents to you
a theme I am going to write
about. So and so. And I'm going
to do so systematically, uh,
one thing at a time in a series of
chapters. That's the route book,
but then there's what he calls
the fascicle book, the, uh,
a book which consists of
complicated offshoots of roots.
But nevertheless,
and tailing a tap root.
And this is what he associates with
modernism precisely in your text.
He says the fantastical book
is like Joyce's Ulysses.
Everything including the
kitchen sink is in it.
It looks as though it
were totally rhizomatic,
but it is of course controlled by unified,
by brought into coherence by a single,
uh,
focusing authorial consciousness
so that it is not truly rhizomatic.
It's a fast sickle book here.
Thousand Plateaus is going
to be a rhizomatic book.
So you have not just two kinds of
books, uh, in this idea, but three,
all right then very quickly
about Jijak
I think it can help us
understand a [inaudible].
I hope you agree and having read it,
but I think in a way it also takes
us back or allows us to revisit,
uh, Peter Brooks. Uh, the, the, uh,
the best example it seems to
me of the way in which, uh,
the tension of desire in
narrative works for z Jack is,
is, although these are
splendid examples and I think,
and I think largely self explanatory.
I think the best example is
actually an another book by,
she's Jack called everything
you wanted to know about Lakai,
but were afraid to ask Hitchcock.
And, and, and, and in that book,
uh,
of course you get a lot of attention
paid to vertigo and just think about
Vertigo as an instance of the kind of
plot Jijak is talking about. You know,
there's that, I forgotten her name, but
there's, there's that really nice woman.
You remember the painter,
you know,
and Jimmy Stewart just pays
absolutely no attention to her.
She's right there. She's available.
She's in love with him. Oh, you know,
he doesn't even see her except
as a confidant. Uh, you know, oh,
yes, you, ah, I'm so glad
you're here. Uh, but, uh,
but he is on the other hand,
obsessed with,
with a woman who,
whose identity he can't even be sure of.
It's not,
it's not just that she's inaccessible
for some reason that she's,
that she's a distant object of desire.
Her identity and the question whether
or not she's being placated by somebody
else remains completely unclear,
unclear for many spectators,
even as they watched the ending
of the film, completely unclear.
And that is an obscure,
not just a distant,
but an obscure object of desire.
And of course the premise of her and
accessibility is what drives the plot.
Now I think that the interest that
it's interesting to think about the
relationship between the element of
detour and delay as eugenic implies it and
understanding narrative,
uh,
the relationship between that and
what Peter Brooks is talking about.
Peter Brooks is, uh, is,
is talking about the way in which middles
in plots protract themselves through,
uh,
episodes,
all of which manifest some sort of
imbalance or need for a need for further a
repetition in a new key.
And much of this hat,
because the characteristic plot of the
kind of fiction books is mainly thinking
about as the marriage plot.
Much of this has to do with
inappropriate object choice, which, uh,
indeed can also in many cases,
Allah,
what I began by mentioning and Jujitsu,
uh,
political inappropriate political
object choice. Think, for example,
about the plot of James's Princess
Casamassima in that regard, uh, uh,
poor hyacinth Robinson strikes out on
both counts in rather completely parallel
ways. He, he's, he ends up on
the wrong side of politics.
He ends up on the wrong side of love.
Uh, and in a way the princess castle,
Princess Castle mass is an exploration
of these two sides of the issue.
But so in any case, uh, for Brooks,
the resolution of the plot is a way
in which closure can be achieved.
That is the,
it is a final moment of
equilibrium as one might say,
or quiet or reduction of excitation such
that the Floridian death wish can be
realized as we know, uh, in the way we
want it to be realized as opposed to,
uh, are being afflicted by
something from the outside. So,
so in Brooks,
who's closest ties are to structuralism,
there is a sense there isn't
achieved sense of closure,
which is an important aspect
of what's admirable in fiction.
Jijak is more postmodern,
Geez. Axes following Laca,
he sees the object of desire as um,
uh,
a sim tonic as being,
ultimately and always inaccessible.
Or if it becomes accessible,
uh, as for example,
on page 1193 and the right hand column
or one might say almost accessible,
this gives rise to as many problems as
it seems to eliminate bottom right hand
column.
Page 1193 [inaudible] says,
perhaps in courtly love itself,
the long awaited moment of highest
fulfillment when the lady Renders Grenada
Mercy to her servant is
not the lady's surrender,
not her consent to the sexual act nor
some mysterious right of initiation,
but simply a sign of love
on the part of the lady,
the miracle that the object answered,
stretching its hand out to this
applicant. The object. In other words,
it has become subject in this moment of
exchange or a mutuality of recognition
or becoming human on the
part of the lady who,
uh, who of course Jijak Jack has been
associated with the dominate tricks, ah,
in a sadistic relationship.
Um,
in this moment of becoming human,
of offering love,
the object becomes more accessible.
That is to say there is now the
possibility of some form of neutrality,
but in becoming more accessible,
the energy of desire is
threatened with dissolution.
In other words,
closure in Jijak is a threat
to the energy of desire.
Desire is something which inheres in
our very language according to Zach and
which, uh, and, and, and which
were it to be understood as,
as, as, as, as brought to
closure. The Lady, you know, the,
the, the, I mean, Jeez, that gives
lots of examples of the lady, you know,
after all this sort of seeming
and accessibility says,
sure, why not, you know,
of course, uh, and, and you
know, and the person is,
and the person is completely
upset and then refuses,
refuses the act because
there's nothing more to desire.
All of a sudden,
all of a sudden,
the whole structure of that energy
that drives language that drives
consciousness, comes tumbling to the
ground and desire has become need.
It's become sort of merely a matter of,
uh,
of gratification through
what's ready to hand, uh,
and no longer a question
of sustaining a dream.
And this and this.
Generally speaking,
is what Dziedzic wants to focus on in
talking about these plots that the object
of desire must be not just
distance but also obscure.
I'm going to make two more points.
First of all,
as you can no doubt tell this is a
perfect replica of Hans Holbein owns the
ambassadors. Uh, I mean, I, I'd be,
I'd be amazed if anyone in
the room hadn't recognized it,
but there it is. There it
is. Um, there's two guys,
there's a table between them.
They are negotiating probably over
one of Henry the eighth marriages.
And this I think is not insignificant.
They are there, you know,
in the service of Henry the eighth
negotiating one of those extremely
complicated marriage as possibly
even the one that led to the, uh,
the, uh, application, uh, uh,
of the Anglican Church from the Roman
Catholic Church. Who knows, who knows?
But the lore about the painting is that
it has to do with the negotiation of an
object of desire and that object
is absent. In other words,
there's something really only implied
by the painting in the foreground of the
painting, notorious to art
historians. There's this thing.
Now this is pretty much
what's in the painting. I go,
this is not a replica of
the two guys standing there,
but this is pretty much what you see
when you look at the foreground of the
painting.
If you look sort of from the side,
it turns into something very much
like a skull. And generally speaking,
there's a kind of consensus among
scholars that it may be a, uh,
a weirdly distorted shadow or
representation of its color.
What's a skull is doing in
the foreground of course, uh,
causes us to wonder as well. Obviously
you can have some ideas on the subject,
but it's still not exactly
realist painting we're
talking about if he sticks a
skull and the forager,
well it also has a certain resemblance
to other things we could mention. Uh,
but the rate,
but the main point about it is that
we don't really know what it is.
It is. And other words, uh,
something we've already become familiar
with and thinking about luck call.
It is that signifier,
that ultimate signifier,
which is the obscure object of desire
called sometimes by Lacan the Phallus.
And it seems simply to be there
before us in this painting. Now,
both in the book in Hitch on Hitchcock
where he finds something like this in
just about every film Hitchcock ever
made and also in whole binds painting,
Dziedzic calls this the blot.
It's, it's, it's, you know,
we have nothing else to call it.
It's a blog.
What's it doing there in fiction
we would call it irrelevant detail.
We can think of.
We can find a way of,
of placing formally,
absolutely everything in fiction,
the weather, what the flowers on
the table, whatever it might be.
We can place formally, but there
may be something in fee in fiction,
which is simply unaccountable.
We cannot account for it.
And that's the block that's
the block for Gj. All right.
Now finally undesired and language.
There's a partner's EGX essay,
which you may have thought of as a
digression and he's suddenly talking about
jail.
Austin's ordinary language philosophy.
He suddenly talking about the linguist,
uh,
do crows idea of
predication in both cases.
What's important about in,
in the one case,
the element of performance and any other,
in any utterance.
And in the other case they dominance
of an entire sentence by predication.
What's important in both of those elements
is that they take over and aspect of
language of which they were only supposed
to be a part. In other words, in Austin,
there are both performatives and
constant it, but in the long run,
the argument of how to do things with
words suggest that there are only
performatives. I mean, I
thought this was a constant,
if I thought this was just
straight forward language,
but I can now see an element
of performance in it. And
that's the way that's,
that there's a gradual changing of his
own mind in Austin's book, uh, which,
um,
to which judge executive sensitive by the
same token do crow talks about the way
in which the predicate element of a
subject predicate relation has a kind of
energy of agency that simply,
uh,
takes over the grammatical subject,
and constitutes a kind of performance in
the sentence performance in both cases,
meaning desire.
When I promise to do something,
I also desire to fulfill the
promise when, uh, when I,
when I predicate something,
I'm also evoking a desire that,
that something be the case possibly
through my own instrumentality.
This is the argument.
That's what Dziedzic means by desire and
language and by the in escape ability
of desire in language and the way in which
it permeates everything we can say to
each other.
And most particularly the way in which
it permeates the plot or as they say in
film studies Daya Jesus of the kinds of
filmic examples that Dziedzic gives us.
Uh, I'd better stop there. Uh, I,
I hope that this somewhat
rapid fire survey of some
key ideas in these texts are
helpful. And I think in
the long run, perhaps,
I hope mainly that you see these two
energetic authors as exemplars of what we
call postmodernism and see the relevance
of the concept of the postmodern to the
study of literary theory.